i asked the question for you if i came
up to you i'd give you 10 million
dollars tell me how you would go about
doing this and you were about to get
into it and you're going to tell me all
this other stuff right let's stick to
that question okay
if i wanted to do this
inside job the 85 were elevated workers
nine months prior to that they took it
away from otis and went to ace fine
it went from public to private fine
silverstein buys it in june
uh fine he buys terrorist insurance in
june great this is very very uh
concerning all these things adding up
how many people who are doing the job to
set up the explosive in the corner would
be sitting there saying the hell am i
doing
okay
what am i really doing
why am i doing this okay and how much
would i do that for knowing i'm setting
up the place to come down
how many total people if they really
wanted to do this this is my number one
question
how many total people who really wanted
to who are totally open to doing this
how many would need to know when they're
sitting because the people that actually
were involved with these elevated
workers
they're sitting there watching this
saying
holy [ __ ] i'm a part of that i
contributed to that
how many total people would that need to
be
to accomplish this mission impossible
mission that we have here how many fair
question
this is not my area of expertise i'm an
architect
um give me a high level
it would take dozens of can we say 100 i
don't know probably not um but it would
that they had nine months to work on it
undercover
they were moving tenants in and around
the world trade center tower
black operations like this are highly
compartmentalized the vice president
didn't even know about the manhattan
project
people didn't know that the joint chiefs
of staff were planning a false flag
operation against cuba where they were
going to blow up a plane full of college
students they brought that to kennedy he
said no
this was only declassified much much
later there are things we don't know
about our government operation northwood
we can't get into that you're talking
about their conscience these people
no no it's not what i'm asking i don't
even want to go into conscience yet i'm
asking you very technical question
if you this is your world you're in
you're an architect 30 plus years you
start an organization that's not got 3
000 plus architects and engineers you're
the founder and ceo that later on you
were fired because of spike lee who you
know the pr came in and said we can have
a guy like this they removed you from
the documentary they cut you out etc etc
fine so this is your world okay
my world is a different world you can
ask me my my world i'll give you my
expertise counsel to you right but i'm
here having you because you're the
expert i'm not the expert on this topic
right
realistically if we had nine months we
got six months how many total people you
said dozens can we say 50 okay okay
let's just say let's play with that 50
people
so
these 50 people wherever they were when
they saw it go down
they're gonna be sitting there
guilty
they're going to read the
stories of kids who are now fatherless
on the cover of people magazine
they're going to see wives crying
mothers crying fathers crying
coworkers crying uh
seeing the country that gave them all
their freedoms in shambles
we look like idiots we look like morons
you can't be that evil
you have to now go to fight this the
only way you can fight yourself you're
conscious with something like this is
probably drinking you're probably going
to be doing drugs you're probably going
to be smoking weed you're probably going
to be doing some things on the side i'm
actually not being funny i'm actually
being very serious you would be full on
suicide no no what i'm saying to you is
when your conscience are you're trying
to escape most people drink alcohol
because they feel guilty they did
something they want to escape a pain
that they're so so now when you drink
what happens you're sitting at the bar
one of the 50 is sitting at a bar he
said hey man is everything okay bro
maybe we should stop drinking bro the
bartender says johnny that's enough
maybe you got to go home today bro
that's enough what's up what's going on
with you i can't tell you bro i can't
tell you okay all right so he goes home
out of the 50 men who were involved in
something like this
most men are naive and
anything they know they'll come home and
they'll tear those wives and
wives are going to sit there and say
babe what are you talking about babe
i feel guilty babe i i don't know what
to do i don't know who to tell out of
those 50 people let's assume half of
them were married out of those half that
were married 25 they told their wives
something that happened say half of them
got a divorce the wife who left them or
got a divorce she has no loyalty to the
secrets she then tells her friends why
you got a divorce and she says listen
this is what i found out about him
eventually this thing's gonna leak to
the world because the 50 who know
really it's really 5 000 people
to 50 000 people that have been told
this story that know that johnny told
larry told mary told jackie told billy
that the reason why johnny and mary
didn't work out is because he didn't he
was working on world we don't know any
of those stories so do we kill all these
people do you exp who would they go to
cnn i mean cnn in in every major media
no it's not cnn podcasts shows articles
magazines writers simon schuster a
publisher we're talking about the crime
of the century which has been covered up
from one end to the other have a hard
time with that and you're also assuming
that these people who planted these
explosives are like you and me with a
conscience no everybody else these are
cold-hearted
the elevator workers are cold-hearted
but it's not the operators but but but
i've met who knows who was in there we
don't even know if they're americans
yeah they may be foreign agents
we don't know but they're ideological
dedication and devotion is
or what their mission is
it's obviously not to help democracy
i've interviewed 15 ci agents on the
podcast okay
and you know one of the best things that
uh
the former chief disguise officer jonah
mendes said i said what are the
qualities of being a great ci agent
charming charismatic great sales person
persuasive attracted
competitive problem only one thing i
said what's that when you do save the
free world you don't brag about it to
anybody okay well
uh every one of the cia agents that i
sit down and talk to they can't help
themselves
not that they don't say everything we've
had the director of ci at our office
before 11 years ago we've got a lot of
interesting things that have former
directors see i've we've interviewed
former director of cias
we've interviewed the former director of
mossad we've interviewed a lot of
interesting people right
man can't keep a secret for too long
man cannot
we don't have that ability long term
we somehow some way eventually
wanna very very very very
very
few people know how to do that and that
very very it's not one percent
it's one percent of one percent of one
percent of one percent that's not a lot
of people okay
somehow someway you're going to be
feeling guilty about the fact that
you're carrying something this heavy and
you don't want to go to bed you don't
want to go to your deathbed with that
now you're speculating and i appreciate
it
and it's a good speculation and i don't
disagree
with anything that you have said but
what you but i wasn't speculating
i was giving cold hard evidence from u.s
agencies uh from video evidence on our
documentary eyewitness testimony
which uh in uh irrefutably and
overwhelmingly proves the explosive
demolition of these towers
none of that is impacted
by your speculation and your correct
speculation that somebody would have
talked
i don't know about that i do know that
i've given you evidence that in a court
of law would bring the perpetrators to
justice for the crime of the century
so uh and it's not just me uh i this
this evidence has been assembled from
the 911 truth movement research millions
of them all together screaming from the
rooftops not getting a word in except on
c-span
mainstream media where washington
journal interviewed me for 45 minutes
guess what
that video became the most watched video
ever on their program more than obama
and others
which were setting records
and yet they haven't invited me back so
you see there must be an arm of control
over the media that you and i can't even
comprehend and i don't think we can
comprehend the control that they can
exert over individuals who who are told
that they're
that their children will be murdered if
they open their mouths
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]